each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you really have to make them by hands
and through quite full of work and
that's a cryptography wood and it's a
good for optimization and absolute
ography is already proven successful in
finding attacks so many protocols were
found to be flooded because people use
formal methods the subject methods and
they found certain bugs and attacks on
those protocols and the open problems
today is first if we cannot find attack
in this abstract model have we proved
anything it's not really clear today and
we don't really know and second thing
you know really big open question is we
have to find it really efficient
procedures for deciding is their attack
in this model or not so there are some
results that secrecy property is
undecidable and for very general class
of product or the question is really are
is this class really what is reasonable
to expect from protocols to be can we
find some smaller classes that will be
decided all or maybe even very easy to
decide not quite clear yet so our
technical background is from behavioral
t of algorithms so space in the work the
Kurian very rich and plus pretty much
did and for different class of
algorithms they were defined by some
postulates and some complete languages
for programming those place of
algorithms forgiven and these are sm
pieces and there are many flavors
depending on which class are we
interesting in and a lot of results here
what we're going to use most for a
photography turns out that we need very
very simple model we're going to need
only the small step algorithms and the
only interaction
inter self-interaction we're going to be
allowed to just going to be import from
a vagrant structure so it's quite
specific very very specific model
doesn't really require a lot of those
later T's is like interactive small
steps and parlo or distributed so few
words about up six states machines are
given by some set of possible and the
first one is that the state of the
algorithm no matter how abstract it is
on its natural level of abstraction
they're always first or the structure of
some pics vocabulary and it's a computer
scientist you can always look at the
structures as memory some kind of
generalized member you have some labels
some function symbols and you have some
number of parameters and if you look in
the structure structure is going to give
you value for dead location and there a
couple of bit much in essential
technical choices that are made all the
bullying and bullying operations are in
vocabulary vocabularies for purely
functional structures and we have this
symbol and element and undef in
vocabulary in order to model partial
functions and without rhythm does out
within transform states so every
algorithm has something called one step
state transformation and the technical
choice that was made was to have the
algorithms can ever change the carrier
and the reason behind it is was that we
can always pretend that whatever we need
it in a later step it was always there
from the very beginning and who doesn't
make the choice we can express what is
the difference between two states
previous and after an algorithm a
transformation so we can just take a
look at all of the locations and we can
see which one were changed and we can
define what this update side of the
algorithm is
Staind so you can again look at the
structures as memories you can take a
look at the memory you can you can see
what locations were changed and you can
just read it without the rhythm does is
changing some location with a new
content and this is called updates the
second post with these eyes more prism
and it says that all states associate to
the algorithm are closed and rising
morphism and the intuition behind is
that really it's what besides a morphism
type of the state it doesn't really
matter what the representation in
concrete structures or states are
whatever it's relevant for the execution
of algorithm has to be represented
explicitly in the vocabulary I mean
means like if you had the red integers
and greenie integers than your algorithm
made different calculation based are you
going to use red integers Iranian to
just it really means that it's not about
integers it's about something else and
also initially states of the algorithm
has to be closed under the isomorphism
the important thing is because the
algorithm has respected isomorphism type
that if we have two states there are a
morphic and algorithm makes a step let's
change that step that was made also has
to respect the same eyes morphism and
the third thing is bounded work so
whatever the algorithm does in one step
is something that is fine it and it's
not even enough to require the public
that is a finite really have to define
what it means to make the fine at work
and that funny face will follow from
different assumptions I mean different
kind of algorithms we're going to have
different reasons and different ways to
express what it really means ready to
keep on step
so here we come to the bount exfoliation
witness the attrition is that whatever
algorithm does in a state it does by
evaluating some terms and based on that
evaluation is going to compute the next
step so the reasoning is that whatever
the algorithm does in two states if all
those if all those terms have the same
value then the work must be the same and
that work is expressed as something that
algorithm change in the state and of
course we have different definitions or
what the terms are and what the values
of the terms are depending on the
algorithms in just non-interactive small
step is just round terms evaluate the
ground terms if you get whatever is the
same you're going to do the same step if
you have interact if you're going to
have also something called answer
function that will give you some kind of
interaction with environment with that
environment reaction is the same and
your state is the same in that way your
work is going to be the same so again
non-interactive have ground terms and
interactive will have something called
extend terms
one important thing that we're going to
use is peg on structures the bank
instructions were first introduced more
is inconvenience than necessity it was
convenient for algorithm to pretend that
when it creates the element doesn't have
to create a pair of the element or the
set of that element it was convenient to
pretend that everything is already in
the state it turn out with our case
study of the cryptographic protocols
that it's really necessary to have bacon
structure you cannot even model behavior
of the algorithm in a way we want it
without begum structures because beg run
because the algorithm would have to
create things that are just not
accessible to him but we do use a big
instruction in solving problem later so
the problem was how to create some fresh
objects without having to create all
those pairs listen and things related to
it so idea was to create a background
vocabulary to have all those symbols
that are needed bears on projections
things for handling waste sets and
whatever and to define those elements on
a set of something called atoms so there
was a unary predicate atomic that was
saying which elements are just atomic
and which structures which elements are
generated by the background vocabulary
so the definition of the background
class was given in a paper of
glastonbury edge and it's also item or
from clovis class that has a certain
properties the first properties is for
every set of atoms you can always find
the structure in that class that has
those atoms as let set as atoms the
second is that whatever is embedding of
two sets between that you can always
extend that embedding of the sets into
embedding of structures so whenever you
have to it two sets of patterns and
there is a wedding you can always find
some unique and bending of those
structures
and the third one is that every element
has an envelope which means whenever you
have some element of the structure you
can always find minimal structure in
that background class which is a which
is the smallest substructure of it and
okay so for some background class to be
regular vocabulary we're going to do the
following thing we're going to require
that all begum functions are static so
the algorithm cannot change what is it
set what is the least what is a pair I
mean this is fixed forever and we're
going to require that if we just forget
about all the functions that the
algorithm is using for some internal
states and you forget about that what we
get is a structure that is from that
background class now we're going to call
expose elements elements there in domain
or quadrant and some four grand
foreground function that means the
algorithm really did some work with it
already so those elements will be
already some kind of sense used by the
algorithm and this is this you cannot
step in the state and the active part of
the state ages vml about it so all the
lists all the set everything that you
can build from those elements they're
already used this is active part of the
state and the definition of reserve of a
heap of the state that the elements if
you can use you can import is just the
atoms that are not in the active part of
it the main theorem is that every
permutation of that reserve extends to
unique isomorphism and wishes entity on
the active part so the reasoning was
that motivation that whatever element
you pick from the reserve it doesn't
matter what you get is always as a
marketing so thing was whatever you do
by importing as it should should be
completely relevant which element which
blank element you choose from that
reserve in that bag of the element are
not use
and now we're going a little bit closer
so the thing that we need and is pretty
much use of snps in cryptography and
this is kind of negative use of the
theory and so far the fury was used
pretty much only for positive purposes
for modeling of systems for testing for
proofs of correctness proof reading
material was always used in a positive
way which is kind of like unlike what
the church in Turing thesis was huge it
was primarily use for negative purposes
to proving the certain things are
impossible and improving this something
is decidable is kind of result but it
doesn't really doesn't really buy much
and the question that we ask ourselves
can really use that theory for the
negative purposes and of course our
application in security was pretty much
financial thing I mean we want the
reason about he and algorithm do certain
things or not and our result the main
result that we are trying to do is
algorithm can undo something so before
which before we go into the direction of
really using this negative purpose we
need to develop some machinery for it
and all of those things were scattered
around the ASM literature but they were
not really ever put one place so we're
going to define a couple of notions on
the structures first as aesthetic things
and we're going to define certain
notions on on state of the algorithm and
we're going to try to relate those
things you're going to try to connect
what the algorithm can do with something
that we can just calculate from the
state so we have the element of the
state is accessible if its value of some
term let's reach the anything and we
also have the finishing of similarity
between those two structures so if the
two structures are in use the same
equality relation on terms then they are
called similar it's different than then
isomorphic I mean this only means that
the part that is accessible to you look
the same to you you don't really know
what it's beneath what is though
whatwhat's interpretation all the
functions are just not accessible to you
by terms
and of course we're going to use a
little bit extended terms and similarity
for examined terms when you're going to
be able to interactive algorithms we're
going to have not just state your going
to also have answered functions and not
just any functions we're going to have
answered function that is only working
from the background which is very
special case and now we're going to talk
about it with some notions on the state
so state reach ability is pretty obvious
I mean you can reach state wide from X's
there is some algorithm that has
information that allows you to go from X
to Y and the term and notion that means
reviews is distinguish ability but it's
really quite a standard thing you say
that after an algorithm make one step
and if it's if it was in the state X is
going to know that so you find some term
you evaluate some turn in the next day
then you have a true you know you are a
next date you wore in the next day so
this is this is definition of
distinguish ability and of course in
this thing we should be looking there is
no such algorithm which is what we
really need and the basic result was
relating those notions so still
unpublished paper will probably on
publishing soon so indistinguishable ax
t is equal to similarity and rich
ability you have to of course you have
to have update set buying it you have to
have all the elements in the Abbasids
finance if you have the same carrier set
then the state is reachable there is
some algorithm they can calculate that
and of course different place the Felger
written going to have different classes
of terms because similarity is defined
for different classes of terms
okay the difference between two states
is finite
in terms of updates
okay is fine if an accessible every
element in the yard safe is accessible
okay maybe I should write a little bit
clearer okay you have to have everything
accessible of course if everything if
everything if the object set is finite
and everything in it is accessible by a
term whatever the term is and the
carrier set is the same then there's a
algorithm in interaction it's the same
just this different definition of terms
and accessibility you have to have a
disability by not just a state state and
the answer function yes and yes like I
said different class of algorithms have
different classes of measuring terms so
non-interactive small step algorithms is
going to be ground terms and if we want
to have ordinary interactive case which
we also studied you're going to have
extended terms theorem is that you just
don't evaluate only in the state you
also need some answer function and there
is also some generalization of if
depending of asset offensive functions
that you things are possible not just
the point of view from what contact is
it is a point of view what you as a
system designer thing the environment
could possibly output so it's not you
restrict those things not even
everything from the background and this
with mature toolbox for establishing
those negative results I mean now we
know what the algorithms cannot do and
we know how to test that thing in a
state we all we have the static notion
that we can just evaluate in a state
without really thinking about how many
steps we have to do things like that and
I would come to the application so its
absolute model of photography from the
SN point of view so whatever the agents
are we going to say the edges are and
ordinary interactive small step
algorithms the only interaction allowed
intersect intellection a lot is going to
be import formula deserve from an
appropriate background and that
background is going to depend depend on
a choice of cryptography that is going
to use public esha key hashes whatever
honest agents are simple I mean it's not
very difficult to program what what the
agents do the honest one is very very
easy but the problem is what the
intruder can do and the point of our
model that we're trying to make is we're
trying to make intruder that can do
whatever the small step out great and
Kendall with this kind of interaction
and things that are pretty much don't
really exist today in apps models of
cryptography is that you have natural
notions for certain things let's say
indistinguishable Utley you cannot
really say that in any formulism today
really used you cannot say the 22 states
of the algorithms are indistinguishable
accessibility of course you have this
kind of secrecy that this normally use
can you access some subject of some
encryption and state variability is
basically what most of the formulism are
focused and i'll give you some idea what
how the computational photography model
looks like on a very simple model and
i'll show you how to relate that
abstract model with the computational
one and actually we got that result for
free so symmetric encryption scheme is a
triple of algorithms so the algorithm
here k is algorithm that given some
parameter like key length and tosses
some points and output some key you can
use that key for encrypting some strings
also click on some points and you would
get some supper text and you can also
use that key to get the plain text from
the certain strings not all and what is
always needed for every encryption
scheme is that diffusion inclusions are
inverse operations so if you use the
same key for inclusion you can always
decrypt that with probability one but
doesn't really mean that this is secure
security is always expressing in terms
of probabilistic bullet time algorithms
and there are many notions of security
in probabilistic photography I mean men
and one of the
test is for us to find something that is
abstractly sound from the computational
model but it's also we have to find a
witch computational model we can really
represent in abstract photography it's
not really clear yet we have some ideas
but this is still open question so we
have that algorithm and we have bearing
we can induce in samples on strings for
example we can take the key out the key
algorithm key generation algorithm give
it some parameter of killing flip some
point generator key and encrypt one and
we can make the pair of debt and let's
say bit 0 and we have definition of
indistinguishability but probabilistic
paulo time algorithm as a function of
the parameters so let's say coins yeah
this for people flipping the coins it's
a it's a key like parameter so all those
algorithm around 1000
okay and depending on the type of those
algorithms on those encryption schemes
you can have that those two ensembles
are indistinguishable that definition of
computational security that would make
those two ensembles indistinguishable so
on the left side we just have encryption
on one and on the right side we have
encryption of a pair 0 and 1 and if
you're just giving that string from that
example you playfully tell where you are
so those two ensembles are not in this
thing we show because you're going to
get a key and with that key you can go
into encryption decrypted with
decryption algorithm you're going to
find out that in upper case you had
encryption on one and down you hear the
encryption of a pair of kids so you can
really distinct resulting boosting info
in a polynomial time so the main idea is
really abstraction we can abstract from
this parameter whatever it's unlikely is
going to become impossible and whatever
is a string which is something complex
is just going to be element of a black
observed area we will not really make
any difference on on the strings we just
make everything is a different it is
represented by one element of over care
instead which is more and again we're
going to use it back on structures and
also whether it's really necessary for
creation in public key case that was
main motivation for symmetric case you
could actually get by without it but it
would be not very elegant and not very
convenient but in public key case you
cannot really do without it so after
thinking about five minutes about that
example it's very easy to make first
simple abstract model so if you have
both key and an encryption you just put
in a structure what the decryption of
that is if you don't have both things
you have encryption in your base set but
it's undefined decryption of design
chessani fine and this is the first
encryption they are not understood I
just view it as black boxes
and what you get for free is theorem by
body road away from 2000
indistinguishability of those two states
implies computational nice English
ability the way that they find it was
not very easy because they had two
different languages and they had to
replace all the encryption with
something called blackboard and they had
to do to find some permutation of keys
to get the same expressions but there
was nothing by the definition of desire
as a morphism it would really represent
their expression with do expression
their eyes in Norfolk two on each other
so if you do like this after five
minutes of thinking you really get the
model that is computational sound with
that respect but they're two problems
with it the first one is learning by
interaction let's say that you make some
step some you get some new message and
you learn what some new key is you have
serious problems because now those black
boxes can be decrypted so whatever your
environment gave you as a key also has
to update your structure two heads all
those decryption now some of the heads
do all that work and it's not really
clear how much that work is I mean its
intelligence work you have to go and
look what you can decrypt now and you
can see if you can you learn some new
key and the clip with that new key so
it's quite complicated process not
really elegant and the second thing is
rich ability of state in the public UK's
so this is the problem so let's say you
have a message we have a public key and
you should be able to create encryption
on it but in order to create encryption
you have to put the crypt in the update
set and the creep is not just any
location decrypt with the private key
otherwise it doesn't work but you don't
have access to private key I mean if you
have the access to private key two holes
the whole model collapses and our
solution was to use the bank
instructions
to make a little bit more clear i'll
give you one simple example how it
really works so let's say you have two
states one in s1 is d in s state you
have encryption of a pair and in the--
you have encryption of a bit one at
first date in S&T they don't know what
the key is but later on they learn it
vocabulary use some function f nori and
g you need the creeps first second and
all and everything that is normally used
in sm states all the boolean functions
and everything else and the base set has
the beets has encryption has a key as
bear and again everything that goes with
the s and state so interpretation in
both those states in both F in both s
and P the function f is evaluated to
improve shin and let's pretty much it
there's nothing else is defined all the
creeps of the pears and let me define so
if environment wants to give you key K
on the input let's say we as a value of
the function G it not only has to give
you that key it also has a copy of auto
logical consequences it has to it has to
calculate what you could decrypt now now
you can decrypt encryption with a key K
and jen and instead pace you would get p
and safety would get something like big
one and after you get that there you
also have to calculate what you can do
with it so you can do projection and the
one left side is going to be one on on
the right side is going to be zero
really have to account for all the
logical consequence this is complicated
now i'm going to define what the
background for symmetric encryption
would be it's pretty much simple I mean
whatever we define in computational
model we just take the security
parameter out and that's it but not
quite those things were defined on
strings but now we have just messages
messages is some kind of union of those
two 30 domains on this three function
this is just some elements of the big
stage we don't really know what their
structure is there just elements of the
bait set
and we said that bed set is really
generated by the bulb functions which
means there are functions and objectives
which means are pairwise disjoint so you
would generate with coins all the keys
that you can generate from those coins
you can generate all pairs of the
messages and with a given key and a
message by flipping the coin to generate
all the encryption so there are infinite
number of encryption for every key and
subject there's infinite number of of
keys and that's not enough we have to
put projections on the pairs and we have
to put the corruption and those two
those three functions will be undefined
anywhere else so if you have a proper
key and you have a proper encryption
you're going to be able to decrypt and
see what the subject is so again this
example you still have this to
encryptions we have the same vocabulary
we have the same base set nothing to
change it but now we have different
interpretations in those function as
before we only have this
interpretational function f is some
element of the base set and that's some
kind of encryption but now we also have
decryption of it we have the projections
and everything those things are not
reachable to us so it's not accessible I
mean we cannot really access for the
decryption e the coefficient of the
decryption of encryption is without key
but it's still in the structure it's
already there and the same thing 14 so
those who structures are by no means
isomorphic but they're similar but for
all the values of all terms all ground
terms those two things are are similar
they're also similar if we have extended
terms and we only have import from beg
on structure you can't really learn
anything from from for the old
encryption by creating a new one let's
not so easy to see but it holds
and now if the environment gives us a
key the only thing the environment has
to do is only has to give us a key
doesn't have to calculate everything
that is it is logically entails from
that so now we don't have to create all
the differences between two states we
just have to give the new information
and we're going to discover and the
algorithm will discover everything by
itself and we get the summons results
for free a riddle for free so in this
thing we should be like a base most def
algorithms is equal to similarity
background terms now again and this is
computational indistinguishability by
budget all the way nothing to do about
it it's already proven it's only study
of abstraction the study of what they
did in their proof in a little bit
complicated way because the machinery
was to ad hoc and they really didn't
have a good means of talking about the
quality of expressions and the natural
motion was really similarity but you can
actually say that without having the
first of the structures its background
another thing is the state we should be
now finally have that that property that
we wanted to we're still not sure is it
really is it's too strong for for
computational cryptography not they're
not really results in that area we're
working on it but the small step
algorithm can generate can create an
encryption if and only if it has both
subject and encryption key which is what
we think about to encryption what it
should be it's not really clear is this
too strong for computational
interpretation for the proofs that
something is impossible
okay and it's pretty much bring us to
the final part of the talking's about
practical implementation practical use
of all this theory so we're going to use
Peck Explorer which is general purpose
tool for specification and testing and
our goal would be to have fast way for
prototyping protocols so we're not
really interesting too much about
proving security right now we have more
concerned about finding attacks and
finding them really fast so we want to
find all the errors in the protocol
before really start usually a pretty
elaborate process of approving security
and what we have is we have a complete
decision procedure for the bounded
number of roles so in some bound of how
many roles can be used in protocols we
can let the spec explorer decide is
their attack in abstract model or not do
it for some place of protocols but very
reasonable one it excludes protocols
which receive an encryption and then
forward it blindly which is not very
realistic and is always questionable
with what the villa doesn't
computational model I mean the
computational scheme usually break if
you just encrypt things that you
shouldn't so these kind of things are
computationally questionable anyway and
we just excluded it from from the first
model okay so the way it works if you
have the honest agent and which is
executing some protocols some medicine
program this this agent accepts infinite
a number of input messages everything at
least everything is isomorphic to one
message is going to be acceptable into
your can also generate infinite number
of messages notice isomorphic I mean you
have some kind of knowledge you can
create all the encryption using it i
mean that's infinite number
but what we are really interesting is
intersection of those two sets but again
still infinite no no it has a finite
let's say it has a finite number of keys
you can generate infinite number of
messages with it just encrypt every key
with every yes has potentially okay
potentially okay I'm sorry so there is
it can generate some finite number out
of infinite number of messages okay and
again those intersection is also
happening but the trick and this pretty
much just reuse of the proof of s and
easiest was that if you really careful
what you're doing you can express those
the symphony number of messages
justifying set of terms cannot really
that many different messages the only
the only couple of them count everything
else is isomorphic similar something to
it so the way it works a consideration
phase in aspect Explorer you would
create some number of honest and
corrupted agents and you would create
some kind number of role random you just
let speck of Torak pickups everything
for you and photographer pretty much
pick ups every combinations so intruder
would ask each row food it will say look
this is my knowledge this is what I have
accessible please give me representative
all those possible messages so the role
really makes the calculation of what can
sugar to give it to me so I would pants
and calculates all those terms and give
one representative to the intruder and
then inspect Explorer again it has the
set of possible parameters and just
takes everyone runs in parallel all
possible roles all possible in fails and
this is all finer things because we have
bound on or number of roles we have
bound on number of messages
if the protocol guarantee is violated
you just stop the search and we display
trace of the run that caused that and if
no more move is possible you get big
nice graph explode for the exits and you
know there is no attack with that many
roles because the procedure is complete
and yeah I could just show it's quite
fast so you're going to start it now
you're going to search a little bit and
here it is I don't know how much you see
it so as you can see in those states I
mean this is just many states combined
one because the graph is too big so I'm
just looking how many rows are really
run things like that and the product the
spec explorer with first create the
agents it would create some responder it
would create some initiator then it will
start with her initial i initiate the
roles or just to run respondent roles
and after few steps in it run run run
run run role you would get into the
state where the check is gay but with
the guarantees fail it all rolls well
yeah I mean UK in one step you run only
one you run one by one but of course beg
explore runs everything in parallel but
it has transitions in many states but in
one state you only run one roll so we
always have interleaving so there is one
action of the role he has some
calculation by intruder again some
calculation through the what what's
output what's input and then again run
on the road so every step you just you
get one role that is run by some message
inspected for it does everything in
parallel and because this parallel is a
lot so I'm just trying not to make huge
graphs and if
yes exploration just it's it's it's a
forward chaining it's there are there
was some work done in this area in a
symbolic trace analysis and pretty much
release what it is but I mean I get here
for free i mean its biggest purchase out
does all the ugly work for me i only
have to specify what the set of possible
messages are and then pretty much
everything else is done by the tool so
what you would get here is this loss
attack when I need to ensure the
protocol I don't know how much you're
familiar with it but this is basically
the trace on it no maybe I should write
it Kimmy I should explain how it works
so you have two agents and they're going
to change some messages yeah maybe
okay there's a protocol goes like this
the first message is there is some
initiator called Alice and once a talk
with Bob and sends a message saying I'm
ballast this is some fresh value if I
just generated and then called months
which cannot be guessed by any attacker
unless it really has excess food and I'm
going to creep this with the public heel
Bob and same to bother with Ellis is
initiator and it has a key 10 I guess
yes
okay we're just going to use okay this
is either name or just public key for
simplicity if it's a name you can look
it up with the public in a web of the
key is for it or in modeling the
protocol visas thing is just to send the
public key so the Alice would send its
public key some knowns and would include
fit with the public health Bob send it
to Bob and the Bob would respond okay
there okay the Bob here would be key one
yes because here Ellis wants to talk to
someone call else I'll show them a tech
layer and Ellis would decrypt this
message with the private key it has it
would look up is this value the same as
this value and if it is it would just
return and two to bob and bob again here
with the Crypt which check is this the
same thing as i sent if it is I'm fine
and the goal of the protocol is that if
a is in this state then a knows there is
a beam this state and that be talks to a
and has exchanged n1 and n2 with it so
Bo the nose here with the N 1 & 2 & a is
so this is 1 guarantee the another one
is V in the in this state knows there is
a a the things talking to be and has
exchanged n1 and n2
so both sides have some kind of
guarantee what would happen and now
going a little bit more black boards are
going to delete this so the data was
found by love is this a things hey wants
to talk to something called E and E is
dishonest so this is intruder and it was
said again a and one encrypted with EE
but because is dishonest does not want
to follow the protocol will do something
with the messages send it to be so it
would say a wants to talk to you you can
do that because you can decrypt this and
create a new one the beasts public here
buddy knowledge it and private keys here
and the B will say oh great I want to
talk to pay as well and it will say
anyone and to encrypted today now II
cannot decrypt this message but doesn't
care just forward it
and they say okay fine with me now e
esse n2 which was originally sent away
Rick rips it again and send it to be now
the guarantee for a is broken obviously
but it's broken because he is dishonest
does not follow protocol so literally no
guarantees whatsoever but the problem
here is that in this state he thinks
there is a the things is talking to be
and has exchanged those two things but
that's just not true so this is what it
finds it it checks all those guarantees
so it's saying if if this person is
honest are going to check the guarantee
if this person is dishonest I will
disregard guarantee and here is a 0
alisis to know Noel assist you no no
yeah okay alex is 0 Eve is 2 and bob is
one and this n 7 is 1 and n 16 isn't too
yes what formula yes yes so basically in
every protocol you have some guarantees
are attached to it and it's if usually
say that if if a is honest and I know be
is honest and be complete
the protocol then there is a role that
has those parameters in it of course
only if they're honest sometimes honesty
yes yes I mean sometimes but this is
this is good enough I mean guarantee for
you if you're not honest it but doesn't
that doesn't really make my Jeep and so
depends and you can have that in our
unique role there's only one things like
that so so those kind of formulas are
what you're trying to check out there
after running a protocol and if this is
violated you just exit and proving that
I don't know for two roles this problem
this modified protocol is secure would
take few minutes with this pack explorer
so you know there are no attacks with
two rows and most of the techs are
really not that big so it's not not
something that you cannot really just
try I mean once you have this running
it's pretty it's not it's not complete
in the sense if you can really decide
security of the protocol but after you
try it with a couple of rolls you know
you're off I mean if it's good enough is
good enough of your roles there's some
there's some results saying some Kieran
saying that if there is a tag there
Israel only attack with not that many
roles but they're not too confident I
mean at least I'm not too confident
about the results how many days do we
have
we wait for me I want to connect
okay here we have 37 I mean of course
because it's a
yes
yeah bro I mean it was fast but yes you
know I mean the thing is the first step
that we did is really looking to this
results from a buddy dog away and try to
interpret it in context of types of
state machines and once you see what
they've done and what they have as a
result it turns out that it's simple I
mean just what small step algorithm can
do nothing more than that and it looks
like really quite good model cuz to
start working this results with testing
it's extremely difficult to prove that
you only have to check finite number of
messages in some format and how but if
you're working in a context of SNP's is
I mean you all have you have multiple
things already proven you just have to
reuse those proofs it's it's it's much
much easier when you have this technical
background I think for analysis and in
those cryptography related results right
now we just imported I mean we have
theorem we see what this formalism is
and what the form is and should be
everything else we just inherit so this
result was not Maya just I mean we just
inherited by the way was defined it was
terrible I mean you have two expressions
then from two expressions you have to
calculate all the keys that are
accessible then you have to replace all
the things in initial expression with
the black boxes each black boxes are
different and then you have to find the
permutation of the key letters for those
two things to be the same but let's
similarity which is much easier to
define much easier to check
I think for now
we made them on obstruction
yes a stream
yes
yes I think it's I mean I think once
once you have a good sound
people
people there is one thing that they were
working on it right now I mean once once
you have this this this framework done
it's a lot of ideas how you can really
search for work or procedures and how to
really decide or final attack because
everything is clean now I mean you
program things in a way you're used I
mean I'm anybody's ever done did some
programming it's very easy to now to see
can I program something like this or not
it's much much more easier than trying
to prove some properties some ad hoc
formalism which you just which type of
study and study and to really understand
what it is and for me this is a natural
way of just thinking about things I mean
this attack was talking about one week
to figure out this and then to write
these tests all together and make it run
because its programming i mean is
something that we are all used to do
Oh
yes
yes sir
we did think of we didn't think about
some something I mean once you have
distinguish ability as an ocean between
on any structure you have logical
knowledge for free I mean this is about
study thing the only question is what is
the relation so you can define what is
the knowledge of the algorithm easily
yeah okay